hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to fatal frame - now we
just made progress which is something
that's very rare and I can't really sell
it right off that often but let's
celebrate everyone cheer I'm not in the
comments just in your own home it's just
randomly wherever you are if you're out
in public cheer away be happy and free
we did it more specifically me did it
okay anyway that's enough of that
too much celebration oh there's the
shadow key oh I didn't know I was gonna
be that easy so where am I in relation
to everything else right now and where
the hell do these doors go why is it
called the lattice room why am I even
here oh that doesn't look ominous it's
been totally silent by the way no music
no ambience just my footsteps and this
is a big open room oh there's the
ambiance okay yeah I was looking what at
the signing glute blue glowing thing in
the middle yeah
URI is not coming back did she really
leave cyi behind did she survive in the
forest
if saya is cleansed and access shrine
maiden' alone
the who might be appeased the records do
not mention any rituals with a single
shrine Maiden but I will do it I have to
try and that was your mistake you
angered it further yayyy
why did you run yay yay yay
why won't you come back no no no she was
a coward she didn't want to die for the
cause or maybe she shouldn't have died
for the cause or probably did the right
thing I don't know I'm not making these
choices I'm not doing these things where
does this go okay then so it's just a
big circular room with nothing Oh
I don't mess ratio dance it looks like
there's lattice things that go down
below
well who's banging a gun out there well
I said about fornicating with pistols
it's none it's unholy you have any idea
who I'm talking about I don't know I
don't even know I don't even know
there's a padlock engraved with a
butterfly design on a heavy looking door
one's calling me
well turn off your phone then okay I'm
out of here
time to go back we got the shadow in the
light keys that means we can go back to
the same place finally do what we need
to do what we need to do is do the thing
and save here and then go to open that
door and finally make some progress but
I gotta admit there are a lot of locked
doors around here they're just locked
doors everywhere I go there's gonna be
so much going back and forth I mean they
put a whole game into this village and
they made it very meticulous to go
through each individual thing yeah you
gotta you gotta admire that you gotta
you gotta a girly thing a hot spa their
spunk they are a little gobble goo you
know
the non-existent race would say the one
that I just made up right now you know
with our long history of her and faded
I've totally lost my mind it's not even
late at night it's like 3:00 in the
afternoon but I recorded three episodes
of that when you record hour-long
episodes I mentioned this and like evil
within an alien isolation when you
record hour-long episodes you slowly
start to lose your mind I don't know if
that makes better or worse videos but at
the end of it I slowly started to lose
my mind I guess I kind of have to deal
with it there you go
yeah that's why we started this episode
off with a lot of cheering cheer for my
sanity where the hell did I just go
Helen I know I've been here wait did I
make a madam did I make an error did not
make a mistake
oh no I know camera
oh-oh-oh I just went to the other door
I did not know there was another door oh
you'll learn them new every day you get
spooked something new every day all
right come on down come with me my you
we're gonna be just fine don't ask why
Adams nother an accent I'm from the
shoulder part of Japan here don't ask
why is there gonna be another monster
Jesus it's not us or is it us or he's
just being possessed by another set of
twins errs this is fate I don't know you
lock the cell with the two keys good
what did I just unleash this we know you
knew what on the table lit faintly by
the paper shade lamp there's some red
stained writing paper beneath the table
there's a Japanese girl doll looking
this way where I don't see that do you
guys see that I'm gonna I brighten these
episodes up a little bit for you but oh
god damn it where are you [ __ ] got you
run your face oh yeah okay so is this
are these the bookshelves that people
were - oh I'm sorry I'm in the wrong
film I apologize I'm sorry I'm very
sorry but from probably maximum I need
to switch it out again I'm very sorry
okay folklorist as expected the jailer
won't tell me anything
won't even say word it's a total
reversal of the treatment I got when I
came to the village I guess it was a
real reason I was invited to live the
sellers also used to stoled arguments I
was able to find several important
manuscripts I can continue my research
but I doubt everyone who anyone who
lives here
hellish abyss oh that's good it is
unclear how long this hole that connects
our world to the underworld has existed
they say that if the cover to it is
opened it will cause a terrible disaster
so this is a physical thing this is the
origin of the gate to hell folk tale as
a taboo word it is often represented in
other texts as well the suffering of the
sacrifice is used to seal the hellish
abyss the mourners they are the
guardians of the hellish abyss and they
are the
can get near it when the year of the
ceremony comes the mourners so their
eyes shut so they cannot glimpse the
hell is a [ __ ] the criminals and anyone
that has seen the hell's hellish abyss
are also forced to become mourners
afterwards they live underground never
returning to the surface what can be so
bad that looking at it is forbidden
maybe because it's actually literally
hell I don't know
that's creepy though that's like
straight out of a creepypasta all right
2028 ins twin shrine maidens are
sacrificing the crimson sacrifice ritual
boys are sometimes used as well in this
case they are called altar twins the
people of this really region believe
that twins were once a single being
which was split into two at birth
technically correct the ceremony is
based on the belief that when the two
bodies have reunited is one the shrine
maiden will gain the power of the deity
the text says the older sister must be
the younger sister throw her into the
war the boy a part of the refer to the
most horrible part of the ritual
probably some kind of sacrifice okay I
got the hammer key I know where that is
okay a Sock'em map the key and the old
map were jammed inside you put the old
map in your file I don't think that's
gonna help me because I couldn't even
find where the other one was okay you
get the sense here of both the
protectors of the village history and
researching full school folklorist books
about legends you can't read some of the
pages what could have been written there
I don't know get out my way did I get
everything was that everything think of
that might have been everything get out
of my way out of my way out of my way
please
oh what's that it's near 90 film yes
please I'm assuming these numbers are
someway tangentially related to how good
they is so 14 is much worse than 90 I
hope but they need I tried the 61 it
wasn't all that good hey the way I got
the hammer Kuh come on let's get out of
here
oh my you Oh
my you know it won't open
would ruther hair yeah he's somewhere
I'll go look for it
okay here okay don't go stay with me why
I'll be right back so just promise me
you didn't hear that scream little girl
don't leave me anymore I'll be right
back I really will wait just a minute
okay
ain't coming back I knew that was my you
okay can I not even turn around you take
a picture
hey you tried calling but there was no
answer you'd better hurry up and get the
keys I knew that was my Yumi Rio okay
you pointed me in this direction I'm
assuming that's where I need to go
that's right I have the hammer key I
don't like this I don't like it no no I
don't want nothing to do with this room
is she gonna come after me
the demons gonna come after me is this
the hole into the abyss this is just
aerated a bit is that what this well was
Oh what am i doing
what about done what are you doing we're
way you and Ellen what the hell you
dingus oh hey hey hey
hey well yeah I'm a ghostly essence it
spilled out all over the floor
oh no makto bless me a rare you
filaments a gluon there you are you were
too hard and find him
what are you doing leave boat which go
what we're do well will pay well where
are you well gosh blasted you blasted a
big blast 33 damage oh I'm on the god
damn and I'm on the wrong film oh I
forgot I was in a bit of a panic I'm
gonna use this type 90 film cuz yeah
yeah cuz I got it and I wants to I'm
gonna get ya or no you did you disappear
oh there you are
what oh you disappeared again oh yeah
I'm gonna get you huh grass yeah I got
you 78 damage that's more like it
that is moral I'm gonna special shot yet
to see you there
give me a good me good shot can I got
you all pass a gun town oh oh that's how
you do it
top 9 to film by B you still life no you
know you're dead you're long gone you
way gone your duns oh oh oh it feels
good
oh it feels good to be a gangster Oh
feels good to be a okay I'm just gonna
upgrade my camera cuz I got a lot of
points I need I need to upgrade my stuff
I don't have as many points as I thought
I did but I at least had a spirit oh I
guess I'll do it to sensitivity you know
how I like to amp up the sensitivity
yeah sorry how does something in my
throat okay so if I can can't I don't
have an appointment I thought I had its
I thought I had lots of points but I
guess the total score is different from
how many okay so the pit of hell is
right there I imagine what was it
yay spirit orb I need that for a thing
oh wait no oh then I would be able to
put that spirit orb right here and
upgrade it at the same time function
powerup you got a baby
accumulation you know how I like tube
amp up the okay I said okay back to the
hammer door I'm sure I'm taking my sweet
time all right
I don't know why she can't run just a
little bit faster like her sister needs
her she needs to be there for her sister
why can't she just go a little bit
faster I'll be lovely all right up the
stairs before I lose my mind more than I
had some strange gunshots going off in
the distance I think I literally gaped
into the pit of hell by looking into
that thing you unlock the door of the
hammer key good for me
you Rea go I have to sew my eye shut the
flash like Oh Oh God for you oh thank
you but it wouldn't come on the house
great observation okay so I'm finally
free I don't have to deal with my you
anymore
yay everybody celebrate again wherever
you are just cheer out loud yeah yeah I
like this is good stuff but there was
also and there's something else here
like that door there is that where I
just came out of I don't think I need to
go back there
under ghosts yeah I don't think I did I
think I'm done here think I'm think I'm
officially done so I can go back out
into the village actually do some crap
and move on with my life
please tell me yes yes oh I thought that
was a cinematic I thought I was cutscene
someone pointed out that there was some
moaning going on in this bridge might
have been me I'm a very who's there
huh
I detect a faint glow of blue my
filament is tingling
hmm this is a little odd nope goofer
there's something over there something's
going on something right something oh
well I didn't even see that if I look
down if I look down
well this gonna be creepy it's creepy
Edgar a bay
oh great a drowned woman oh great great
great so glad I got that but did I not
get any points for that was that just
for oh it's just for my own personal
collection you know whatever what a
weirdo
mmm carry on
you that frickin place nothing okay am I
supposed to leave I mean it allowed me
to go outside so I'm only operating
under the assumption that when I can go
outside again finally it wants me to go
outside even though I chased my you into
that damp in that damn place left her
there is that just the music of this
place hand I need to look at the map
I didn't look it I wasn't looking in the
map before okay what is that oh gods
village there's there's a stairway up
here and a doorway over here so if I can
go up here I might be able to do
something I need to find the key to her
cell even though it's like she's not
even locked in the so she's locked in
the room outside of the cell why is that
locked more there was something down
there I'll get it next time if I
remember well I'll get it right now
because I'll have to remember right now
all right whatever
damn it I don't know where I'm supposed
to go if I have to wander the village a
bit more than I
supposed to be here or if I'm just kind
of passing out personally but let me go
outside that's what the hammer key did I
gotta believe that this is right place I
gotta believe it gotta believe I have to
believe I have to believe in myself
so if I go up this way there's another
door up here but then again I don't know
if that's what a bespoke to you
whoopty woo oh wait no oh okay there was
a notice go see you up there but I
forgot I forgot I got a map I got a map
before that I didn't look at the Osaka
House he's a mark inside one of the
walls now where was the Osaka house now
if I can find where the Osaka House was
then I would be able to know wait was
the other thing the other house if that
was then that doesn't make sense and
where how are they two houses in one
that's a good question but there's a
mark inside one of the walls so there's
gotta be a hidden thing somewhere so I
look at the map to be able to change
floors Osaka house oh wait what what is
that
that doesn't look familiar at all where
was that
okay keen where was that where the heck
is this what is it what is this what is
this place huh where where was that was
that back was that back where I was was
that in the same damn building I if I
have to go back there I will be pissed
Kass I have to go back don't I god
dammit you ghost I want to get you had
I'm not close enough damn it I have to
go back very upset this isn't it this is
gonna be locked it looks like unit oh oh
I can is this deal house if this was the
Osaka House said I'm gonna be very happy
what psych house Kira Reaver new house
okay well I can go in here at least is
something so I'll go back to the Osaka
house later after I explore all what
this place has offer yes let's just go
wandering only all of Hell has spawned a
key why why why why is that a thing why
is that happening
okay oh whoops I didn't mean to do that
I wanted to watch that thank you very
much okay all right please fill me so I
can swap them out about that way I
wanted to watch this this has to do with
the ritual and this has to do with the
friggin portal hell I don't think the
portal the hell was in that basement in
that well I don't think that was it that
was probably just normal well I'll know
when I see the portal to Hell
cuz that should be pretty obvious yeah
cockroach are you just documenting this
for posterity or is there a purpose
behind this also what time period is all
this in look at I'd say that these two
twins my U and mu you know are from a
more modern era cuz whatever but like I
don't know
exactly okay so that was a thing I'll
just take it I guess oh never this is I
don't know I don't know so lost was this
crappy to heavy cloth sways in the wind
good for the heavy cloth is there
something behind the heavy cloth is
there a thing is there person mind a
becaus I don't know let's go through
doors are given to be locked well that
answers that question I guess I'll just
keep wondering yeah I kind of Miss
having my you around cuz at least she
was a distraction to the ghost that
could take her first but now this is me
just a whole out of me going on here neo
going up mm-hmm
I don't know why but this game it's like
occasionally I'll just get periods of
lose where it's like oh yeah I forgot
I'm a little girl wandering alone in
just a totally abandoned hell spawn of a
village and I'm probably gonna die gray
room is divided by sliding screens wait
with that same paper or the sign-in
screen surrounded off you can see the
whole room beyond great
oh I can't open this one good good okay
that was a weird camera change to make
you got a man you gotta admit that one
this is where the ghost was wandering
around so okay that door seems to be
locked so where the ghost went I can't
get to it's probably a good thing
because I don't I don't go there let me
just get in here and I'll listen to this
crystal radio me up babe great glowing
green was that it stuck in a hole in the
hallway floor it knows Chris and a
barrel knows it
okay all right let me just listen to the
glowing green here coming I've already
listened to this one okay all right then
God you know one things I don't like is
the wailing of the Damned like just
kinda you know a constant drone of
unending suffering you know that's why I
mentioned it last episode I think but
the stun power of Y a stun I'd rather
hit him hard maybe that'll stunning but
you know the wailing of the Damned
like I mentioned event horizon in the
last episode her and maybe the episode
before that but event horizon is one of
my favorite horror movies like just cuz
it was one of the first ones I ever
watched and it may be like a little
cheesy now or whatever but I think it
still holds up pretty well and I really
wish they would find the lost footage
from that that movie The Guardian deity
statues in this area are different in
that they are engraved with shrine
maiden's the village children say that
the statues honor the gods of the
village also a book in the house links
to statutes to something called the
Crooms who sacrifice maybe the forbidden
ritual is related to this grooms in
service I think I think I needed to be
here before I went to the other one so I
think I should have been here before so
that is my bed but either way is Lee
stomach at least I'm exploring it now
hopefully I can find something out of
all of this then I'll go back and then
I'll go in the isaku house or whatever
it was okay well I guess I'm going now
so here we go we're all done here
finally okay so the only reason to come
in here was to get a little more
ritualistic information but heck I
already got the later ones I already
answered my own questions about why I'm
here and what I'm doing and why I need
to be here and why my sister is going
crazy
let's go back out I know that I need to
go back in to the other place yes go
outside thank you very much thank you
for hurrying me through this adventure
okay what else do I need
that's just least nowhere god it's here
okay so I need to go back to the Asaka
house which apparently was in the other
building was it in the other building
okay hang on
I'll be right back I'm gonna figure this
out before I just keep guessing that's
right I just remembered I just confirmed
it like I was pressing the wrong button
to change floors I do need to go back to
the Osaka House because that is the
first house I went in that was it like
that was it I knew I knew I remember
that guy I knew it hello
what are you doing hello goodbye lured
woman you were to way by the crimson
butterflies wait aren't the crimson
butterflies good or are they not really
good and you're just telling me that
they're good where are they lying to me
the whole time I like that thing so yes
I feel betrayed in whatever endeavor
that I'm doing around here
for running away oh is that you sigh II
say sad sad yeah II sigh which one was
the more guilty one who wanted to say I
think those ie yes please this is your
Sakai house I'm going to find the thing
that's hidden behind the wall and then
probably not probably not prob and I
don't even know if I die in this game if
I got a game over thankfully I haven't
died yet thank you very much I have not
accept all those times I just remembered
that I did die to the big goes to you
never mind it go my previous statement
I'm an idiot
forget what I said I've died lots of
times why did I think I didn't die
Wow okay this is another example of me
going loopy forgive me
I'm just carry on please oh now I know
the commas separating me they're coming
again oh why why why use to be so cruel
to me
I play get freer David why are you so
mean I don't know not a one ear and not
a one there's not a damn thing that
anyone could say that could possibly
make me sad or mad at you guys you guys
are the light of my world and you guys
are all beautiful and I appreciate
everyone
so I guess bring it on bring it on what
do you got try to make me cry like a
little Babu sounds open
there isn't anything special good to
know okay so it was back was it back
this way I know there's an easier way to
get up doctor yeah it was this way so
it's in this room in here so this is
gonna tell me that I am screwed whoa
whoa hey whoa that wasn't good enough
what that wasn't good enough that was
right on him
ah
whoopee whoopee ice a whole lot of
poopie on that one okay so I need to go
to this run that's the way I'm going
here so go through here then straight
ahead straight
hey was it was this way right yeah it's
up against this wall somewhere that's
what it was what was it
mortuary tablets and incense burners on
the family altar okay Oh feel wind
coming from him from a crack in the wall
part of the wall looks like it would
slide to one side but it seems to be
step oh come on
what will bash it open
bash it hard what am I supposed to do
get it unstuck
what is this baloney god damn it what
what you can't lead me to the place
where you got maybe on the other side of
the wall like if I go around to the
hallway what am I supposed to do I don't
have a bash button I don't have a try
really hard I don't have a pick up a
crowbar and smash it open button well
this way there's got to be something in
there there's got to be something in
here that I can use like a lubricant
maybe fatal frame alarm when if this
function is equipped it sounds a tone to
warn you at the exact fatal frame okay I
didn't think there was supposed to be
anything else here I thought this houses
I see you there I see you I see you I
see you I saw you don't
village report okay maybe they belong to
the missing surveyors for some reason
one of the statues is in the form of
twins I have also found a description of
twin daddy's statues in the writing
lying around the house I looked down
into the old well but it was pitch black
and I couldn't see a thing if you listen
closely you can only hear wind blowing
up and it seems that the water has all
dried up I can't tell oh maybe I was a
portal to Hell maybe it really was okay
I found a small shrine at the top of a
long set of stairs shrouded in mist it
seems very old but it is well made and
has not fallen into disrepair the
entrance has a large
butterfly I came to this hill to take a
look at the gate I passed through when I
entered the village but when I tried to
find it dot-dot-dot
okay oh that's it then
but why am i standing in a ghost I am
literally walking through ectoplasmic
goo why what is it boy yes what's up ein
hello as you want from me what is it why
is it just ghosty goo there there's goes
to you right there is lingering left
over bull is that actually something I
don't know I guess I just got to explore
the rest of this house again because
apparently there are new items and new
things to be had again Oh
BRB oh oh oh whoa hey don't be peaking
what are you peeking on you're peeping
tom that's disgusting
okay was that the only thing in here
don't tell me that was the only thing in
here Oh spirit orb okay I guess that's
good well I guess this is a who's there
who's there
girl in hiding hiding really well thank
you
what is it wait why why why why is all
of this thing well there's the first
folklore the ceremony Massa I miss our
Kurosawa gave me a very warm welcome the
village has no chief the ceremony may
surprised over the village i one of the
villagers founded by the people who
wanted her as the sacred rituals and
festivals most are well among all gods
folklore is a key to a legend that has
been Passover yes it is an archetypal
tale of a year to hold the mark the
border between the world of the dead
they called haze underworld and another
water there's a forbidden place that is
feared and hated but it's also
worshipped as well well the idea of
having better core believe in humans and
since ancient times it feels supported
here with the believers Universal the
forbidden regional regarding this hate
hell they take plate here's honey you
know what is allowed to see us big up
this trick taboo is probably the Roses
everybody concerns its waters with hell
coming close to the living world bill
just lead a simple life deep in the
mountains they struggle for you don't
daily meal's the visitors look harder
with the outside world
they continued practice away to the old
bruising in time well there you go
everybody I have officially circled back
as far as I could have possibly gone and
went back to the beginning and now I
don't need to be here anymore and this
is a big waste of time so what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna fast forward till I get
back to where I need to be which was
that house that I left because I thought
I needed to leave it oh it probably
needed to happen is I just need to cycle
back around and go back in the front
door
whoa whoa whoa who is who where is who
God where's who
I don't know Jesus Davis baby
yeah yeah F face was all kinds of you
know what was the point of that oh yeah
why yeah I don't know why I didn't even
think about it but it totally left my
mind the woman who is like with the
butterflies she was headed this way
like why didn't I know that why didn't I
see that I think that the the kid that I
was talking to was over here yes it has
come to this
PJF Danielle Rachel oh no I feel so much
shame you should is that blood on your
front which one is you get it I get I
get it now okay I get it now
yahi why did you leave by yourself it's
our fault that this is happening it's
Itsuki you promised we'd always be
together and yet we're not fluorite okay
that should have some good good good
good thoughts on that one but I need to
save before I get to it thank you very
much
the creepy goobers this game is getting
creepier as it goes along like I mean
the encounters with the ghosts aren't
all that scary but men's creepy
wait I have to fluoride Oh crying in
front of the stores okay this one I did
leave my you there for a long time okay
okay all right then well that's that
then
we gotta go in the store house now
apparently for some reason door seems to
be locked
ah but I can go around it yes I can go
talk to the dude who's not alive by any
stretch of imagination probably
definitely not here yeah what does that
say that a little less distortedly
this befell key I think they keep it at
the Osaka do not break the pinwheel seal
to get to the basement there no I was
just oh no no no oh yeah
Oh both of you need to leave the village
thank you you can't keep letting them
perform that ritual
oh yeah butterflies butterflies in my
soul I cannot believe it I just I went I
was I once again I did not follow the
breadcrumbs I just need to follow the
breadcrumbs I did this I caused this if
you don't realize what happened I need
to go back to where I just was because I
didn't come here first for someone to
tell me that I needed to break the
pinwheel or whatever whatever it was
which is honor bullcrap but I guess you
know I I totally ignored it because I
thought I knew where I needed to go I
thought I did the map was just like a
clue too soon like give me the map at
the same time man ah man I'm too smart
for this that's what it must be I'm just
- I'm too handsome I'm too good-looking
I don't use smart is this its curse it's
a curse that I deal with on a daily
basis I'm too good for this world that's
why I'm an utter failure and everyone is
yelling at me in the comments
that's why oh okay
so I need to break the pinwheel which
means I need to make the colors match up
so there's probably green which means
that this probably blue this one could
be orange but you never know with these
oh okay so I only have a limited number
time so this can be solved in one go is
what you say okay so yeah yeah huh yeah
that didn't do it okay so I almost had
that but I got it backwards I needed to
do it the opposite way of that ah ah
that was easier than five just I was
thinking about it wrong again I was
overthinking my broom my brain by giant
Blaine would do big AG I'm done
defending myself
I am undefendable I'm undefensible I can
go in here now we can go to the secret
basement all right cool have I forgotten
totally about my you yes yes I have Oh
cave hey let me they update ready damn
it I probably could taking that a lot
earlier I just thought I need to be
closer all right
stone mirror no more can be carried
stone mirrors and I'm that face is fun
okay
so pre Hemi a night let's listen cuz
I've got nothing better to do a a night
somebody was someone trapped down in
this game
underneath the house I'm thinking yes
ding ding ding that's the answer oh boy
I can't carry any more than 14 film as
if I needed any more of that Oh
that's an interesting empty suitcase is
enough for destruction hello you look
boss like grandpa stronger its blind oh
I have not saved in forever if I have to
stealthily go through this
oh you dingus beret I wouldn't imagine
men made a mistake like that I'm gonna
exercise no hang on I need to do this
first wait a minute hold on a second ter
sonny jim I've got lots of type 61 film
that I'm gonna shove up your on here we
go now it's time to tango now it's time
to Jango ah I did that goddamn ah oh
because I press triangle to try to do a
blast I didn't have enough juice dad was
it ok ok though that was bad time come
on come on come on Joey come on what you
got oh god damn it what that's like
instantaneous I don't have time for that
ain't nobody got time for that and I got
a run by you yeah how do you how do you
have like a lock on me now whereas
before you definitely didn't well we'll
wait whoa whoa back up that I I am whoa
what why why can't I get a combo why
can't I get a bleedin bloody combo
anymore it's like impossible to do well
here you there that's a good shot I
guess catching them from behind it will
ok run run
a freaking frack I got nowhere to
maneuver don't get a double combo shot
on me when I can't get a double combo
shot on you
now I'm gonna go
he's dead he's dead one down used some
herbal medicine whenever I come up on
these lakyn tight corners and like I
don't have a lot of room to maneuver I
just look bad even though I said to the
world how good I was and usually that
works a bunch of dickory that's what
mrs. just up on tight circuit break
rusty key maybe it opens that door door
to my you she's going to be a little
changed when she finds me okay so that
was a film rule role I can put that in
the film projector in the other place
then I'll be good
did the other deaf one or blind one go
away now my okay am I gonna be okay
probably not I'm gonna die horribly just
really oh don't do that
whoa No oh hi hi there BAM God that
didn't work what the hell wait what wait
wait a minute oh there you are okay I
see you oh god you're weird like you
schoolgirl face you gonna do about it
huh go back up for another go I got a
lot to her yet hey hey BAM double blast
oh so much damage so many points for me
still gonna be over there you gonna move
you
why what why a whole bunch of this oh
god damn it damn it damn it where she
kamal dishes she's a she was coming
quick oh my god i get him good one more
honor - yeah i'ma it's best to keep the
camera out I think it's good I could be
at the ready
why what Oh God I know you didn't I
didn't miss you there you go oh no I'm
dead
was that just some random ghost or was
that just a scripted one I guess didn't
drop anything yes you did okay I don't
think she dropped anything I think I
need to go for it it was gonna be a
problem in my filament my spidey senses
may be tingling I do need to learn to
not take pictures with the X button I
need to actually use it the trigger a
lot more because that split-second
difference is the meaning between me
missing something and B actually killing
something or me being killed very very
well okay but anyway I am all out of
time for this episode
don't be spitter spattering all over the
place with your dumb camera angles in
your movement I am all that time I'm
still enjoying myself thoroughly I did
wander quite a bit this episode and I
apologize for that but I'm getting good
at the game I'm learning I'm learning
it's a learning experience everybody
cheer for learning ray learning
learnings good stay in school don't do
we don't do drugs
eat your milk I guess that's it for now
so thanks again everybody so much for
watching that's the last one I'm gonna
record for today but thanks again
everybody and all your suggestions and
comments are well appreciated unless
they're totally making me cry which you
can be feel very bad because as soon as
I read them after I record this just
gonna cry nice
as always I will see you in the next
video
no running I'm dead I'm already dead
ready